Hey youtubers, it's Charlie, this is going
to be my Agents of SHIELD episode 14 video,
lots of Captain America: Civil War stuff brewing in the background, so I'll try
to explain how they're integrating that into
the story,
along with the Inhumans stuff. It's funny how the TV shows are laying the
groundwork for movies that are years away.
Captain America: Civil War is coming out
next year, so it's not that far away,
but it makes sense that they use the TV
audience to create awareness
for big stuff that's going to be happening
later on. So just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet, starting up with top 5 moments.
Number 5: Pulp Fiction intro. If you didn't
recognize i, they used the exact same
diner that they used on a show last week.
The tone of that opening scene between
Ward and Agent 33
is almost exactly the same as the
opening scene from Pulp Fiction, when they
start with the diner heist.
Funny because Tim Roth, who was in that
opening scene, played Abomination
in the Incredible Hulk and Agent 33 kinda thinks of herself as an abomination
Very meta Marvel 'verse type stuff. I totally love it when he gets referential like this.
And I'm totally digging the creepy sexual stuff that's going on between
Agent 33 and Ward.
Very clearly that's gonna turn into some
kinda ship, whether or not it lasts I don't know.
I think it depends on how stable Agent 33 stays. Clearly,
like, she's still recovering from what happened to her, she's imprinted,
on Ward, but I think he's manipulating
her just like people manipulated Ward.
Ever since he showed his true colors, whenever he's really earnest like this,
when he's just seems
too nice, it's way too good to be true, he's definitely lying through his teeth.
I do think that he's going to keep his
promise to Skye, he's going to reunite her
with her father,
and her family, this other Inhumans group, but the real question is what else is he trying to do,
that can't be his only goal. I know a lot of
people are wondering if he's
turning into like Taskmaster from the
comics, I don't think that's the case,
I think is going to be his own thing,
he's an original creation of the show. He's just a villain, his character, that operates
outside of the boundaries
of the major organizations, so he's not like
completely HYDRA, not completely SHIELD,
not even really much of an anti-hero, I still think of him as a villain,
like a free agent equal opportunity
villain. Seriously though we have to talk
about that Skye lingerie scene, that was so creepy,
and so much fun. I am so happy when Agents of SHIELD can make my skin crawl like that.
I feel like a lot of the fun on the show, a lot of the humor, is going to be born out of
this crazy Ward storyline.
And when I see humor, I mean really dark
humor which
one of the best kinds. Onto number 4: the real SHIELD explained.
Edward James Olmos' character, Gonzales,
isn't straight out of the comics, but it is totally setting up
Civil War, like all this secret SHIELD
versus real SHIELD stuff
is setting up what's going to be going
on Civil War, who is accountable to who,
transparency versus operating in the
shadows. That's like the big difference of opinon.
In the comics, Civil War is very, very
different, it's all about superhero registration.
Captain America doesn't think the superheroes need to show their faces, Iron Man says they need to.
It's way more complicated than that, that's
like an oversimplification.
But the emphasis for Captain America and
Iron Man drawing a line in the sand
is gonna be different in the movies than it is in the comics. They kinda explain
this a little bit when he did that the
Marvel Phase 3 announcement, where
they introduced Chadwick Boseman as Black Panther.
I might do some more Civil War comic book videos in the future,
but because the TV show and the movies are gona do something different, I'm mostly
gonna focus on that stuff.
Edward James Olmos' gonna be a lot of fun though this season, I love seeing on again,
especially in a really like contemptuous position of authority like this:
a secret organization inside of a secret organization.
Just to explain what Mack and Bobby have been doing for real SHIELD
while they're inside of Coulson SHIELD: they're looking for the Toolbox and
they're gonna be trying to find out
where skye is. I also thought it was funny
that all those people,
including Hunter, still think that Nick
Fury is dead. I don't think they were lying.
I said it a couple times before, but I think
at a certain point in the movies we will
see Secret Avengers.
I think it will be till we get to Civil War, but eventually we'll get there.
There'll be two different teams of Avengers, although technically the Avengers will breakup
and there'll be two teams of superheroes. I don't know if either one is going to call
themselves the Avengers.
Onto number 3: Skye goes to Inhumans' summer camp.
Totally loved the way Fitzsimmons were arguing about which Avenger Skye was most like:
Captain America or the Hulk. Technically
I think Simmons' more right because she
can't really control her powers right now,
but they ask a really important question: if Bruce Banner could get rid of his
powers, should he be allowed to?
Because he does do a lot a good as the Hulk. The problem with that is that none
of those characters have read the Illuminati.
That's the story line where Marvel's
Illuminati the group, Reed Richards,
Iron Man, Doctor Strange, all the other
Illuminati,
including Black Bolt, shoot the Hulk into space because he becomes
such a problem that they can't deal with.
Obviously they're not gonna be shooting Skye into
space anytime soon, but I think it's kinda funny.
Because, yes, you know, Hulk is good, he is an Avenger
but he also causes as much damage as he
prevents. So it's kind of a wash.
In the comics though, Daisy Johnson, the character that Skye
is on the show, she does joins the Avengers eventually. Her upgraded gauntlets
look pretty cool, it looks like they're full on-gloves, I think Coulson called them gloves.
If gaining mutant powers is a metaphor
for people becoming sexually active,
I mean that's originally when it was in
the comics, then think of these gloves as
a chastity belt,
or birth control. I guess if they were a chastity belt, they would completely block her powers.
Make as many condom joke as you want, but basically which is gonna be doing at
this cabin is just playing with her powers.
I think it's gonna take her the rest of the
season to figure powers out
until we get to a gloves off kind of
moment, metaphorically and literally.
She'll take the gloves off and be like
crazy, do something like crazy big.
it just really really easy expectable that they could put in the finale. Like it's all about,
you know, humor, heart, expectable and the expectable part being the big superpower stuff.
Onto number 2: 33 and Ward are
brainwashing Bakshi.
This was so much fun, you know, nice twist on the Whitehall scenes.
What they probably gonna do is try and
brainwash him, replant him
inside HYDRA, and use him to run counter
operations against them,
or they could still program him and
replanted in back
inside the US government. If you remember in the midseason premiere,
all the heads of HYDRA said that Bakshi was the next best candidate to become a
new head of HYDRA,
to replace Whitehall, so it's possible that that could still happen.
And speaking of Whitehall, this is really
important, because I feel like he is the
one common villain amongst
all the different groups on the show. Don't you just feel like they're laying seeds
for him to become the overarching villain for the Inhumans, as well as real SHIELD,
Coulson SHIELD and Agent 33 and Ward, like their little splinter cell.
It's like, despite all their differences of opinion, everyone agrees
Whitehall is awful. So just open up a tab
in Chrome for Whitehall
big bad return. And finally, my number 1 WTF moment:
Coulson and May totally know something is going on with Mack and Hunter.
Whenever there's a character on screen lying to Coulson or May,
I always get the feeling that they secretly
know they're being lied to.
It just feels like in the past, in the Avengers movies, as well as in Agents of SHIELD season 1
Coulson always knows when he's being lied to. He might not know exactly what's going on,
but he knows when you're not telling the
truth. That's just more fuel
on the Civil War fire. The really question we need to ask, and actually here's my big
question for you guys, you can just answer in the comments,
do you think that, you know, once all the
secrets come out
about real SHIELD that Coulson'steam
will reunite
by the season finale? The other possibility is that it could split down the .
So then during season 3 you have a lot
more SHIELD in-fighting.
They're totally gonna do Captain America: Civil War-SHIELD crossover,
just like they did in Captain America: Winter Soldier, and just what they're
gonna do in Age of Ultron,
they're always gonna have minor crossovers between the films the TV shows. I do think that
real SHIELD versus SHIELD will continue
to be a thing in season 3.
It just feels like it works too well within the context of Captain America: Civil War
for them to get rid of it right away.
In related news, Daredevil is getting
ready to premiere on Netflix, so if you
guys don't have Netflix, make sure you get it,
it's gonna be an amazing TV series. I'm not expecting it to crossover
with Agents of SHIELD or the movies a whole lot, maybe in season 2.
I think they just wanna started as its own thing first, just to see how it does.
They're also setting up Jessica Jones
and all these other Netflix series, so it's
is largely gonna be self-contained to
these other shows that are on Netflix.
Be sure to subscribe to get all my
videos. What I'm gonna do is, I'm gonna start
doing more Daredevil bonus videos as we get closer to that.
It's really only a couple weeks away, it's
gonna be a lot of fun, make sure you go check it out.
I know everyone's wondering if I'm gonna
do like videos for every single episode,
or if I'm just gonna do a couple videos. What I'll probably do is I'll just do
like one video for every two or three episodes and just post one every like three or four days.
There's just like no way I can make like
thirteen different videos in two days.
It's also the same weekend that Games of Thrones premieres. Daredevil drops the
Friday before Game of Thrones season 5 episode 1 airs, so
it is gonna to be such an amazing weekend. I probably won't sleep but it'll be a lot fun.
While you guys wait for that you can click here to learn all about the Captain America: Civil War directors
taking over the Avengers franchise for Joss Whedon, that's gonna be really exciting,
and you can click here for all my other Agents of SHIELD videos.
Thank you so much watching, now let's all high-five, I'll see you guys again tonight.